i time a hotel lighting is like using
the wrong color foundation on your face
harsh I gotta ask yourself you do not
know 99 but it's different now it's
Friday here on the if grace channel
which means attended comment and put
text message is convenient key with
humans and tires with some physical
likes just in it's like living phone to
my new sitcom called I'm all-in true
virgin
whoa attractive is kind of coming on to
call my let's go role quitter go like
plumber's new person apart to tell you
do not know when new person comes over
my social media platforms like grace the
crowd Pelham welcome to this great
certainly haven't noticed new person I
know I just get you should think too of
an ungreased people could what do you
mean you could be dumb head of rescue
person I said this already
oh my god just feels so long time just
great people it oh god I didn't mean
when you can be dumb so like clone what
let go khlo just go just go just go
you'll be great
we need more vlogs this week so cold oh
did you enjoy the medieval times one
that I posted this Monday because I
really did I used to do friary here on
this channel a lot and I've gotten away
from it and maybe I'll start it up again
but no promises so everything she's kind
of the same as an oasis everyone loves
being a relationship with someone that
never gives them straight answers only
gay answers what I have a ppl to person
to person to person pineapple ppl when I
was ppl camphor pineapples penis sprayed
well your was rude what oh no
I'm broken doing great I'm a huge crush
on rage and botanist grace helbig's
brother hashtag a crush hashtag single
for life will crush up my brother I'll
show you crush I was in high school a
very very big crush on the boy who
played Billy Elliot in the movie that's
a musical everyone else like mineral
Cabrio I got kid to played Billy Elliot
ha dirty girls you bring diverse new
person pretty girls more like this dude
supergroup I thought watch dirty 30 for
the first time just now an idk why I
waited this long it was amazing I swear
I haven't
a series of spambot accounts in which I
just treated myself complementary things
about work I've done outside of YouTube
so that I can use it in videos
commenting on my own comments in order
to promote these projects that have been
created off the platform of YouTube I'm
glad you're like 30 30 and will be
available I think on Amazon and iTunes
and like maybe target still no good and
Grow Rich glad new person
person-to-person Chris grab or like
crystal labia
Chris geez labia script G you're never
gonna see your labia likely I see like
Google Image Search the other group okay
like here's the deal why do you always
introduce your videos with hates Friday
here on it's great like that that that
[ __ ] its front it everywhere cry face
cry face extra cry face emoji sometimes
people watch my videos on dates sit on
up Friday [ __ ] I called you [ __ ] I
don't like on people [ __ ] I have a name
- grace Gaelic for [ __ ] jack on his for
1855 to prison for diversion Jack I'm
just 4265 more like Jack Nova scores
because he was born in the year 1865 and
it's very creepy to everyone that he is
still living human being trending
grabbed him by the [ __ ] I'm sorry ye
olde [ __ ] you wrote a tongue of that
man oh that tongue his mouth could not
contain the speeds of it you know you
can contain Steve fish back off buddy
brother hug them out in a weird pervy
way that's flattering I'll pass the
message along to him just having a
little browse because the first new
person just having a little browse more
like just have a little browse more like
it using my trappers net just collect
some Wow
plus/minus there roaring bedroom dresser
sometimes it's just my girlfriend just
touching your remote great it looks like
you're thinking about hot kisses so DME
girl oh no bags bags home to person to
person to person fan sent 12 more like
Eve six super Brooke she looks like
Hillary Clinton from afar crisis Crisis
crisis
I've never heard of the movie afar is it
good it's Marc Challon apartment version
Bergman miss Marcal while I'd miss
Marcal sounds like the winner of a very
very very sad beauty pageant so swimsuit
it was mine three videos in three days
break you've outdone yourself lady don't
get used to it
at all whatsoever your guys please
subscribe that's gonna get you back
Thompson new person first new person
Zach Thompson more like zach tops and
needs a job see you race you Jersey
showing I'm so sorry
Liz beep each new person hurts new
person Lizzie peds more like Lizzie
impeach a president oh never rude or
some bizarre reason I thought the
thumbnail said I farted too hard and I
think that would have made an
interesting video love this too though
[Music]
Betty dot dot new person cars new person
Peggy stalked adds a more like I bet
your name's Lena Becca yet but you're
not even the girl at bay you're a male
never grew I'm always scared graceful
grace to crap on me one day because my
name is not actually Becky and I'm a
male in fish Daisy new person person
person Kim fish TV more like queen [ __ ]
please you're rude how do you get like
regular friends I have no idea let's
google it together how do you get like
regular friends oh one of the first
articles that comes up as 12 differences
between a normal friend and a Polish
friend so maybe try that website well
there you go that's over commenting on
your comments it's weeks thank you guys
so much for leaving comments across all
my social media platforms I'm at grace
Helbig across the board make sure you're
following me and commenting so that
maybe you can be included in the
commenting video on a Friday in the near
two distant or never future don't forget
to subscribe to this YouTube channel
this is not the appropriate hand gesture
for that basement brain and body work
together please make sure to subscribe
this youtube channel i make videos
monday wednesday and friday sometimes
and sometimes not those days and
sometimes extra days who knows give this
video a thumbs up if you like commenting
videos i know to keep doing it other
than that
I don't know oh just studios new person
first new person alleged student is more
like that sounds like a pornography
company big time you a new to this
channel any recommended videos to catch
up on an authentically a new person one
answer all of them tell all of your
friends and get all of your friends
caught up make sure their subscribe and
let them know I'm not desperate
I'm very low-key to even not extra also
sometimes live a very long BAM